well the nato meeting this week was a
show of western unity and strength in
the face of russian aggression but
divisions of course do remain between
the uk and the eu closer to home
specifically over the northern ireland
protocol and the british government's
plans to change or scrap parts of it the
eu says it will respond with legal
action some think it could lead to a
trade war so what is the state of the
relationship between the uk and the eu's
largest and most powerful nation
germany's ambassador to the uk mcgraw
berger joins us now thank you very much
for being
with us um i just want to start with
ukraine after that interview with lord
danette who said that the perhaps the
most likely scenario is the war goes
into deep freeze russia takes the
donbass and it's very difficult then to
get those russian troops out is that
also germany's assessment
yeah i think it's one of the possible
outcomes of this terrible war that we
might go into a deep freeze but you know
i would not exclude that russia might
push towards odessa because we have so
far not seen that putin has scaled down
on his ambitions
and putin is watching very closely and
the the unity of of the western alliance
but you know i think the messages which
came out of the g7 summit especially the
nato summit
with the 300 000 troops now on high
alert i think that at least has sent a
very strong message towards russia
given the russian aggression that you
speak of there
do you feel that germany has been a bit
sluggish in
providing heavy weapons to ukraine
particularly in comparison to the uk and
the us
no i i would say that the difference was
that in germany we had really to change
totally
our approach and that was made by
chancellor schultz in his speech very
early in february on site and vend which
means really a total new approach
concerning 100 billion for the german
army which means that we are going to
have the largest armed forces in europe
again we have started later than the us
and uk sending heavy weapons but i think
the multi
rocket launchers which we are sending
together with us and uk
but also the hovitzer self-propelled
hobbitses i think they are already
having an effect we always can and we
have to do more
and
sophie my concern is really that we as a
as nato as western alliance we have to
be capable of supporting ukraine if this
war drags on for weeks and months and
that will be also a challenge for our
armed forces
i understand of course the shift in
german position but it has taken a while
to get to this point this is president
zielenski just two weeks ago every
leader of our partner countries and
naturally the chancellor schultz of
germany knows exactly what ukraine needs
it just that the deliveries from germany
are still less than they could be it has
taken a long time for you to get here
you will acknowledge that
yes as i said we started later than
other countries with the delivery but
you know we have done other issues for
example we did
exchanges of arms with the czech
republic allowing them to deliver
russian-made tanks to ukraine we did the
same with greece we sent our
missile defense systems to slovakia
allowing them
to send systems that is something that
other countries have not done so if you
take the overall picture i think germany
is very close to what the uk is doing
and of course germany is very reliant on
russia for oil and gas do you think you
rely on russia for more than a third of
its gas and the german foreign minister
has said that there's a hybrid war going
on as russia cuts those supplies to
europe how concerned are you about the
supply of oil and gas
yes i think we have to be
very concerned especially on gas on oil
we have managed to reduce in the last
two three months the dependency from
over 30 percent to only 12 percent
because you have an international oil
market where you can get oil from other
countries on gas it's not so easy you
need infrastructure
you need lng terminals we have invested
in them
so we have bought four floating lng
terminals which will arrive in germany
before the end of the year
but obviously if russia and russia has
reduced gas delivery to only 40 percent
so germany has declared gas emergency
and that means if this continues or if
russia would really cut gas supply
that we will have to
stop delivery to some
sectors of our industry that heating in
the autumn and winter might turn into a
problem so i can tell you there is quite
some concern
um okay i want to talk to you a little
bit now about the northern ireland uh
protocol if i may you're in belfast at
last week
do you accept that the northern ireland
protocol currently isn't working and are
you optimistic that there is a solution
that can be found
yeah you know for me it was very
interesting these three days in belfast
talking with with all stakeholders
and the impression i got especially from
the business community is yes there are
problems especially for
small retailers and we think they need
and they can be addressed
the majority of business told us that
they are working very good with the
northern ireland protocol what they need
is certainty
certainty in order to attract investment
and this certainty is definitely damaged
by the northern ireland protocol bill
and i can tell you that we are very
concerned
that this bill which is not only
um from the point of view of
international law it it it would really
um break an agreement which the united
kingdom has signed and ratified only two
years ago but more than that it brings
uncertainty to northern ireland next
year we're going to have 25 years of the
good friday belfast agreement and i
think it should be our joint endeavor to
do whatever is possible to have a
functioning executive in northern
ireland um an assembly and a business
community which can move forward so just
to be clear because you mentioned
international law that you believe that
the northern ireland protocol bill
breaks international law that it's
effectively illegal
there is no doubt about it and i think
theresa may has said all about this
position we share it
this is breaking an agreement and i
think that
lawmakers house of commons they should
be very concerned about what it means to
break an international agreement how
that will be seen at the international
stage so how can we see how how will it
be seen what will the reaction
you know it will obviously be seen as a
challenge to international law and to
rule of law in general
and so i think the best what can be done
is to go back into legality and that
means
let's negotiate find technical and
practical solutions on the basis of the
protocol the european union is ready to
do that but what we also cannot accept
is a challenge and a risk to our
internal market so what would happen if
the uk government does press ahead with
it are we talking about a trade war you
know i i
only can tell you at that stage that all
options are on the table
and i would not exclude any one of that
but really our call is let's go back
into negotiations this is doable it's
solvable and it's in the best interest
of northern ireland okay and just very
very finally i'm going to squeeze one
more question in um
looking ahead we have the world cup in
qatar if england win their group and all
the other rounds as well and germany do
the same
they'll meet in the final
bearing in mind that you're a diplomat
who do you think would win that one
that will be a fantastic game because
always england against germany in the
world cups was
were great games so i'm really looking
forward to that but now first of all we
are looking forward to the women's
european championship in england
and there we also have a very strong
women's team competing
well that is a textbook diplomats answer
i have to say thank you very much for
being on the program this morning thank
you thank you for having me